Prüfung Telc & Goethe
Start Deutsch 1
Das Komplette Vokabular mit Dialogen
Lektion 4
47 Wörter
Los geht's
der Laden – die Läden
legen
das Buch – die Bücher
Im Buchladen können Sie Bücher kaufen.
Legen Sie die Bücher auf den Tisch.
Gute Bücher sind oft sehr teuer.
welcher/welche/welches
bestellen
abholen
nächster/nächste/nächstes
die Woche - die Wochen
geöffnet
Welches Buch möchten Sie?
- “Heidi“ von Johanna Spyri.
Dieses Buch haben wir nicht –
sollen wir es für Sie bestellen?
Ja. Wann kann ich es bei Ihnen abholen?
Wann kann ich es bei Ihnen abholen?
Nächste Woche.
Aber beachten Sie:
Der Laden ist samstags nur bis 16.00 Uhr geöffnet.
der Reiseführer
vielleicht
1000 = tausend/eintausend
1.000.000 = eine Million - Millionen
1.000.000.000 = eine Milliarde – Milliarden
Ich kaufe mir einen Reiseführer für Berlin.
- Brauchen Sie vielleicht auch ein Wörterbuch Englisch/Deutsch?
In diesem Wörterbuch finden
Sie mehr als 20.000 Wörter.
der Kiosk
der Bleistift – die Bleistifte
jeder/jede/jedes
die Lebensmittel (pl.)
Am Kiosk bekommen Sie Getränke,
Zigaretten und Zeitungen.
Bleistifte können Sie auch an jedem Kiosk kaufen.
Aber Lebensmittel bekommen Sie im Supermarkt.
die Zeitung – die Zeitungen
das Getränk – die Getränke
die Flasche – die Flaschen
Ich lese gern diese Zeitung.
Mein Lieblingsgetränk ist Bier.
Eine Flasche Bier, bitte.
die Zigarette – die Zigaretten
über
18 = achtzehn
19 = neunzehn
rauchen
Wie teuer sind die Zigaretten?
Sind Sie über 18?
Ich rauche nicht.
Ich frage nur.
1 g = ein Gramm
500 g = ein Pfund
1 kg = ein Kilo/Kilogramm
der Apfel – die Äpfel
Ein Pfund Äpfel bitte.
wie viel
die Banane – die Bananen
die Birne – die Birnen
Wie viele Bananen wollen Sie?
Drei, bitte!
Ein Kilo Birnen, bitte!
das Obst
das Gemüse
die Tomate – die Tomaten
dieser/diese/dieses
Im Sommer ist das Obst billig.
Gemüse brauchen wir auch noch.
Die Tomaten sind sehr gut.
Wir nehmen lieber diesen Kürbis.
die Anzeige – die Anzeigen
die Reise
fliegen
lieber
die Bahn
Wir haben Ihre Anzeige in der Zeitung gesehen.
Wir möchten eine Reise nach Deutschland buchen.
Aber wir fliegen nicht gern.
Deshalb fahren wir lieber mit der Bahn.
der Anschluss
bleiben
von (von Saarbrücken nach Trier)
circa/ca
(sich) freuen
In Mannheim haben Sie
Anschluss nach Saarbrücken.
In Saarbrücken bleiben Sie drei
Tage und dann fahren Sie nach Trier.
Von Saarbrücken nach Trier sind
es circa hundert Kilometer.
Die Fahrkarte bekommen Sie am Bahnhof.
Ich freue mich auf den Urlaub.
Weiter geht's im nächsten Video!